uh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
all right am i coming through that
that's my friends is the question
oh it would appear so let me just adjust
that
there we go that's a little better
uh hope people are doing okay
beautiful whistling
thank you thank you very much
uh i do all right as a whistle i'm not
that impressive
did you hear about helen mccrory i did
that's a shame i didn't really um know
her from anything
other than um her role as narcissa
malfoy but
she was uh fairly young so yes that is a
shame did i trim my hair
no no i did not um i'm due to
trim up the sides in the back but uh
but otherwise no oh ben
don't nod so hard that you strain your
neck all right
be careful about that ah
was she whistling because she's in a
sitcom someone asked her to act normal
it really doesn't work in real life does
it your whistle it just draws attention
so my suggests peaky blinders for
something else with helen
mccrory very good show i've heard very
good things about it
um i don't have time
to i mean i don't even right now
really have time to watch the things
i've been commissioned to write
cause i need to get the damn book done
which
as the title to the live stream implies
i really should be doing
right now um i'm not
i've called it a day on that
but um yeah i don't
i have no idea when i will be in a
position to do
fun uh viewing again
like watching stuff that isn't because i
intend to get a video out of it or i've
been commissioned to review it
i don't know when i will have time
for stuff that's just for me the closest
i come is
uh when i'm with liz
i'll we'll watch stuff together um
like that but like when i'm on my own
nah
nah your sides come in very quickly yeah
they really do
yeah my my hair gets up to a
um certain length uh pretty quickly
once like it's i feel like it's been
this length forever
i feel like this isn't getting much
longer um but yeah this
this comes in quick uh it is very true
fun is not allowed it's sinful said the
englishman
wow i i have the joy of having
uh be being generationally distant
enough from my um english roots
to have largely shaken that off
at least i like to think so
as a i have a lovely cup of sin
ah let's see i like this heated debate
over
twitter discourse setup
oh twitter like honestly
if i didn't kinda need it
for you know promotional purposes and as
a way to for people to be able to
contact me
um because i just i have gotten
contacted
uh directly through twitter and
sometimes in meaningful ways and i
honestly it was helpful with the book
also um
[Music]
i was surprisingly efficient for finding
illustrators
but like just as a general thing
i really don't have a lot of use for
twitter anymore on a personal level
like professionally i have some use for
twitter
and i do try and use it recreationally
a little but i have very little use for
the platform
anymore if i ever did i never really
sank that far into twitter
and i feel like there's multiple friends
i have
who you know will have a down day
and i'll be like are you doing okay and
they'll be like oh you know i was on
twitter i'm like
stop stop going on twitter
you'll probably have a better day i'm
just saying i mean i go on there
basically to post my own stuff i do not
hang out there
i do not i do not sit around that
that spot that's very red water you
should have the taps looked at
i look i i don't know if you need to
check your screen
or if you've got some kind of filters up
on your
on your displays or something but no
this is crystal clear so
i don't know what you're seeing i'm not
responsible for that
fun fact sin is a greek word an archery
term
interesting uh
do you beatbox good grief no
[Laughter]
um oh i feel like uh
this is worth um
getting out there and having it said
um
the guilty verdict
for derek chavin i believe is his name
in the uh in the case of the man who
killed george floyd
that was really good to to get a news
alert on
now i will see what the sentencing looks
like when we get there
but that was
honestly kind of a relief
a bit of a relief honestly
not dissimilar to the election results
just the sense that
there was a result that to me
was so clear the best thing that could
happen
that i was dreading
the opposite and it's nice to have
things just not go that way
once in a while so
i mean like obviously there is not a a
direct relation between
the outcome of this trial and
trump losing the presidency but as far
as how it is
felt the weight
that gets eased on my soul
there is a link and there is part of my
brain and my processing that is going oh
thank god that relief
of the election results wasn't a fluke
there
will or can be other moments of
relief of things not
going horribly wrong
now that having been said
much like with the election itself
uh this is not the point to simply go
whoa we did it problem solved everybody
you can go home like no
no this is a ongoing problem and we've
had
stupidly recent instances of
effectively the same thing so
nobody especially if you're white
do not act like this means everything's
good now
cause it's not this is a
lovely indication that maybe things can
start to head in the direction they
really freaking need to but
do not sit back and get complacent i'm
gonna try and not sit back and get
complacent
but that having been said the sense of
relief honestly i can't even say joy or
anything like that because a man's still
dead
but like it is relief
that sense of relief is very real
and for me at least it
right now it has value and i i
i benefit from that at the moment
so uh
funny enough i only reactivated my
twitter account just to follow you
it's been so long that i used my twitter
that i still have to
uh save the ba you lady ladies
i saw the save the bau ladies banner
across my
uh profile interesting i'm flattered
oh thank you very much uh oh geez i am
going to
butcher this um because i don't know
if it should be done continuously
or if i should be pronouncing those
letters separate i'm going to go for
that
uh kj zana channel
thank you very much have a heart
um and folks who who contribute to the
super chat that guarantees i will read
your question i
i you know i try and address the chat as
best as i can
as it goes on but a super chat
guarantees that i will address your
question or comment and you also get a
heart
so thank you very much have you heard of
the small
acts film anthology that steve mcqueen
directed last
year it's astounding how he can direct
five feature films all at once
i had not heard of that
um i'm gonna have to look into that
because no
i'm not familiar with that one i'm gonna
have to remember like honestly
if you are on twitter at me like
tomorrow
um because i'm i'm gonna
largely be unwinding this this evening
or at least trying to
uh so the odds of me remembering uh or
addressing it immediately
unlikely but you know uh nudge me on it
i'd appreciate that it's me connor oh
hey connor i i and i can't guarantee
you'll remember that either
like remembering names that are not the
names that are up on the display like
that
it's it's not it's not a skill i have
today's verdict should hopefully be the
beginning of justice and reform agree we
should not be complacent
justice maybe um i do want to stress
that right now
that result like the idea
of moving on to reform which we need to
do
but that's where i worry that there will
be
complacency because for some people they
will look
at this outcome
[Music]
of and the guilty verdict and think oh
look the system works
but that's the thing the system is
fundamentally broken at a lot of levels
just because it worked
this time this one time that does not
mean it is not fundamentally broken
to its core on a lot of levels
especially when it comes with what
police are allowed to do and get away
with when it comes to violent
action against honestly anybody but
especially black people
so we have to be very careful that a
guilty verdict is not interpreted
as the system works because no
it doesn't even a broken clock is right
twice a day
this was just the instance that was so
egregious that even the broken system
couldn't stop it from getting to a point
of
actual legitimate justice outcome on it
but that is not an indication that the
system works
[Music]
i'll explain at the time around 2010 cbs
forced my favorite show
criminal minds to uh controversially
acts two-thirds of its female cast
before season six
caused a huge outcry oh goodness i did
not not
i did not know about that
not broken built that way yes yeah that
is actually a very good point
john the the unfortunate
truth is that
the justice system
much like the stock market and the
capitalist
um system and the way
that companies are allowed to treat
their employees
and fire massive swathes of staff at the
same time that they post record earnings
are not flukes they are in fact the
system working as intended in how it's
designed to be
which is something that i wish people
would really
wrap their heads around because if the
system was designed that way
then the only way to improve it is with
forceful and deliberate action
because it was set up to be like this on
purpose
so you can only change it on purpose it
is not going to naturally incline
towards a better outcome
thoughts on jingle all the way never
seen it don't wanna
uh
have you seen heard of six the musical
yes
yes um god that was getting
brought up in the chat a few months ago
on a semi-regular basis um
probably by ms wicketwolf at a guest uh
i
yeah liz introduced me to that actually
i like it quite a bit um i like
uh i like catherine howard best
personally
uh number five um but no that's a that's
a great show
that's a lot of fun and that that music
is fantastic
um
got some very bad news from here in the
uk the lgb
alliance has been granted charity
registration by the government
well [ __ ]
so for anyone who doesn't know
uh the lgb alliance is basically
um unified turfdom
it is a deliberate and uh overt
removal of trans people
from or from certainly their
sphere of the queer community
and with the stated and flat out
um deliberate intent to
excise trans people from
the queer movement and queer culture
and probably from the face of the earth
if they could have
their way
god damn it
that's another thing i um
i'm starting to um
to look into a bit more about
uh some of the legislation and i can
honestly just only look at a sampling of
it
that's either been proposed at the state
level or
in the case of it was either alabama or
arkansas
actually getting passed in terms of the
restricting of the rights
of trans people specifically targeting
trans teenagers and anyone under the age
of 18
because i need to do a video on that
probably on the
um vera wild channel
because i'm overdue to do an update
video on there and and i don't have a
way of
um really tying it into pop culture
and without that hook in it feels weird
to address it here other than on the
live streams i suppose
but
i'm fortunate to live in a state
that isn't going in
for um
a lot of this nonsense and
there are a lot of the um
proposed legislation i mean that's
something to keep in mind there are
literally hundreds of bills being
proposed
um and a lot of them are already
stalling they're stalling in committee
they're clearing state houses but not
state senates
um but part of what's really
infuriating about all this and i didn't
even realize this i stumbled across this
um this fact
by accident while looking into other
things related to all this
in polls taken they're several months
old now
but you know they would have been around
in the lead-up to the election
when asked republican voters
don't back these bills a majority of
republican voters
don't see it as don't see trans people's
rights as an issue
or even think that they should have if
not equal standing at the very least
equal access to medical care and when
asked to rank
the priorities of
the issues at hand you know which would
you know issues like the rights of
transgender people but also
things like a woman's right to an
abortion
and um the current state of the economy
and international terrorists like all
these hot button issues gun control all
this stuff
eve and this was republicans polled they
put
transgender bottom last
as a priority
so what this means right now is for the
republican party
they see people like me
as the easy target as the easy win
they can try and get
when they're down because
they lost the
white house they lost the senate they
desperately want to win and
certainly within the bubbles that these
people tend to exist in
guess who is still considered a valid
and viable target
and at the very least you won't get in
trouble for going after
like republicans target all kinds of
people
but they can't do so openly in most
cases
republicans can't pass legislation that
openly flatly
goes against the poor goes against
black people goes against hispanic
um latin folks they can't do that
without serious pushback but they can
openly flatly
come at people who are not cisgender
and even if they can't get their
legislation passed it is
no hit whatsoever
to their standing either as individuals
or as a political party as whole
it is totally fair from their viewpoint
it's honestly the reason they're pushing
all this stuff
is because it's a zero loss situation
if they don't get past it's not going to
hurt them
and they can say well we pushed for this
and if they get it passed hey
look we got stuff done
that is the current state of trans
people
in the country that i live
we are such a viable target that there
is no
political downside for the right
to target us
because you know they didn't have our
votes anyway so they don't give a
crap about us they don't have to
and there isn't enough backing there
aren't enough allies
to push back
so they do it and they get away with it
thank you very much
alex you get a heart
alex daisy thank you i've been watching
your content for free for a while now so
i decided to change that hope you're
having a good day
oh thank you i've got stuff going on
you're my
on my mind as you as you may have uh
have guessed
from my or my rambling so
like it's been better
but like on a personal level
you know my life my house my family
i'm all right i'm doing okay
so thank you
uh
have you seen spielberg's the adventures
of tintin no
i'm meant to see that
um it was on my to-do list forever but
it just i
everything there were just other things
that felt like higher priority
ah yeah
uh oh somebody was putting in uh or i
think it was connor
uh was putting him 420 light up yeah i
don't
um i don't i just don't
like it's funny i um the job the job i
was at
the one that i was at for about nine
years they had um
random drug test which i actually uh got
picked for
at least once might have been twice um
while i was there
uh but i i
so just for that reason alone i got out
of the habit
and i don't feel the need to go back to
it
um even now that i'm you know
self-employed and
my own boss and it's largely legal now
but like ah
i just don't feel the need and actually
you know it's funny to me
with 420 i feel like
i don't want to come off i don't want to
harsh anybody's buzz
but like i can't help but feel that
most of the people who are like yeah 420
are people who are probably smoking the
rest of the year anyway
and 420 rather than being an excuse to
partake
is rather just an excuse to tell
everybody how much you love it
i don't think there are that many people
who like wait until the day and there's
probably some but i can't imagine that's
that is very many
um any plans to watch the bad batch yes
uh actually i'm probably going to give
that a shot
um and
i i hope i hope it is not
too buried in um
in animated star wars lore because
i haven't seen i've seen bits of rebels
i haven't seen clone wars and i'm sure
there'll be references
but i
i am willing to try this one because i
it's a chance for me to come in while
it's
fresh and i would like to do that
and uh yeah i'm gonna give it a shot
hopefully hopefully i don't feel
alienated
by too many callbacks i i would like to
think
it would be fairly newcomer friendly
since it's going to be the first one
premiering on disney plus as a service
but we'll see
oh hey there fairies uh question close
to my heart
what do you think of the reddit doctor
who leaks
probably a lot of bs but interesting to
discuss
i'm uh i'm unfamiliar i
i abandoned reddit probably about a year
ago
um i
i think i mean like um ben just pointed
out i'm generally
not inclined towards leaks in the first
place
because i just
they're either true or they're not and
if they're true they'll be an official
confirmation later
and if they're not true then i'm getting
worked up over nothing
and they just don't they don't seem
worth the brain energy to me it's not
important enough to be
like ahead of things for me it doesn't
matter that i know
first i'm just not that kind of person i
don't really
care that much i would rather know that
it's
true than know it early if that makes
sense
um but as
as far as reddit itself goes like i
think uh i don't know
what point it was but but there was a
point where
about half the time i would um
post or comment on anything i would just
get anti-trans stuff
thrown at me or even in transforms get
um things like transtrender thrown at me
so i'm just like
i know what i'm not welcome like i still
technically have an account
on reddit i didn't delete my profile or
anything but like
screw it
unlike twitter which i can justify in
terms of
i there's these benefits to being on the
platform like i couldn't think of any
being on reddit at this point honestly
thinking back to your top 10 movie
scores list oh boy that is going back
away
if i were to do one i would choose glory
as a james horner one and really tempted
to include
uh merry christmas mr lawrence okay
don't know that one
i actually don't know the glory
soundtrack that well i haven't seen that
movie front to back
i've only seen bits and pieces of it
seem fine
i mean civil war is not a uh
period it is civil war right or is it
revolutionary war
i can't remember uh old-timey american
wars
aren't exactly my wheelhouse um
what are your thoughts on liar liar i
have not rewatched in ages to my
memory it's one of the jim carrey movies
that holds up
better that doesn't mean it holds up
great just means that it holds up
better uh it looks like it may
have some ties to clone wars would
recommend chloe
everybody has recommended clone wars to
me i'm sure it's great i didn't skip it
because i think it's crap i just like
time time i say watch the first four
episodes of steven
season seven of clone wars as though
those episodes have the bad batch in
them
i mean i probably won't do that either i
appreciate the recommendation
but realistically no i i probably won't
bill pope is the cinematographer for
shang chi
oh dang really i did not i did not even
realize he was going to be doing
okay oh i kind of wish i had realized
that he was um the cinematographer on
that
because that would have just knowing he
was there would away laid at least
some of my fears that i expressed um
when i reacted to that trailer
sorry i might have missed something but
my thoughts on the trans right thing
you were talking about trans people our
people and politicians
have so many other problems to deal with
yeah
i mean that's that's the thing though
but like
trans people are as i said right now
seen
politically as a very clean target and
there are some people who like
legitimately hate us
like very very very deeply
but there are plenty of people who
usually
people in political positions who are
moving against us
more out of uh political expediency and
attempts to gain political clout
than out of abject hatred
but there is some of that floating
around there's
plenty of it truth be told
um if it's mr and sir for men
and ms or mrs and mam from
uh women what's for nbs
um
kind soul friend
fellow human
you know take your pick uh or more
realistically
uh ask uh as someone who identifies
firmly as non-binary as opposed to a
wishy-washy ball of gender nonsense like
me
[Laughter]
yeah i understand not having enough time
though i have all the time in the
in the world right now uh maybe i'll pay
you to watch it sometime if i get a job
hey that that's what the patreon's for
jesse thinks you're hot everybody thinks
i'm hot
you have eyes it's a visual medium
moving on gloria is about a mostly black
civil it was civil war i knew it was
about a black battalion i just couldn't
remember
which war it was uh so thank you for
that rowan
do you think christopher eccleston had
the potential to be one of the top five
doctors if he had more than one series
i think people are well within their
rights to label him as a
top five doctor even with one series i
think he did great
whether or not people think it was
enough to rank him that high i mean
that's an individual choice
i mean i've always said there is no
wrong answer
to who's your favorite doctor or who are
your top five favorite doctors
so like you say it as if there aren't
already people who put him as a top five
and there are i've met some
there was a post on twitter casting the
wiki movie is like choosing a restaurant
for dinner i don't have any good
suggestion
uh but i know i don't want anything uh
you've said yeah that i mean that
honestly that sounds like fan casting in
general which is why i don't generally
indulge in it
fellow human sounds too jokey and isn't
suitable off the internet
friends sounds best of those well i mean
people are pointing out um
some folks do use mix mx
um but it is one of those things that
um hasn't really taken a
firm grip
on uh
on the general pop culture so we'll see
if it sticks
i mean it makes sense it would work i
haven't seen any marvel stuff because
there is too much seriously giving other
comic companies
a shot well look the other
other comic companies there's really
only one other of note
um in terms of superhero stuff
definitely and that's dc
uh dc has had a shot and the fact that
they are
floundering behind marvel is not
marvel's fault
dc did that to themselves
so you know that is not marvel's fault
if you think there's too much marvel
stuff
and you're intimidated or don't want to
dive into it that's
fair but the lack of stuff from dc is
not marvel's fault
shame you've got no self-confidence
there very i know
i'm so insecure
and uncertain and
lacking in confidence in myself it's
it's really sad
ah let's
gotta bounce tonight everyone good night
andrew thanks for stopping in
uh my friend was watching your old vera
wild videos she was thinking about
referring to you as
v because she thinks it's cool i mean
like she can
refer to me as whatever she likes i'm
not in the room this
is polite merry christmas mr lawrence is
a queer themed japanese prisoner of war
movie starring david bowie
why don't i know this
why do i not know oh
i really feel like that's something i
should have known
thoughts on howl's moving castle it's
fun
i enjoy it i think it's a little
underappreciated
um actually as far as miyazaki movies go
um i feel like some stuff of his is a
little overpraised i mean like i know
spirited away is a little overrated
i'm sorry it is it's good it
like almost everything that i say is
overrated it's still
good it's just not the end-all be-all
that a lot of people say it is
oh comp girl thank you very much
you get a heart thank you for the shoot
shooper
super chad
oh god love that smile
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh i'm bumping the camera
i actually got to have it photographed
um
[Music]
over the weekend i don't know what i'm
gonna have pictures from that
um but i haven't had a photo shoot
in probably close to two years
maybe more than two at this point it's
been a long time
i've missed it and this was like really
quick because there were a bunch of us
there it was
um it was for a pride calendar so you
know the people were only there for
short periods and the next group had to
come in
um but uh oh it was nice
to be in front of a camera again i'm
pretty sure you've heard the main theme
for merry christmas mr lawrence and
not known i mean once i hear it i'll
i'll
probably find that to be true
ah i'm seeing some love for labyrinth in
the chat
always support that i love 99 of all
studio ghibli movies
in fairness i haven't actually seen that
many ghibli movies that
aren't directed by miyazaki himself
i have seen grave of the fireflies but i
haven't seen stuff like
um the cat returns or only yesterday or
marnie was here
or tales of earth sea um
oh i saw i did see um
secret world of very eddie which he did
not
um he didn't direct that one
so i i've seen a couple that he didn't
direct but
i've seen his whole filmography
um for his uh feature length stuff
dark horse comics valiant comics and idw
are just a few i can name off the top my
head
um i'm not
disregarding or disparaging companies
that aren't the big two but
they're they're not playing in the same
field if you're talking superhero comics
basically with a handful of exceptions
which are mostly
parodies and pastiches you're talking
marvel and dc
i mean i was tempted to bring up image
but honestly image at this point what
they ha what they have the rights to
that's actually
good isn't really their superhero stuff
so like if you're talking comic books in
general and you're saying
things other than superheroes i agree
but again
superhero movies being big doesn't
preclude non-superhero comic books from
getting a shot
you know so i i i feel like we're we're
talking past each other a little bit on
that
discord oh thank you carowind i will
check that in just a second
time for my hot take heaven's scent is
overrated especially at this point world
enough in time
the doctor falls is better
no comment because um my reviews for
world enough in time and the doctor
falls my my revisit reviews aren't up
yet so
no comment uh if there is a labyrinth
sequel
which i don't think should happen i
don't either uh
i really want to see inside the worms
house
at the risk of being tactless is it okay
if i describe you with male
pronouns when casually discussing you
please do not
um i do not use masculine pronouns
anymore
and i kindly ask that if you are
referring to me you not use them either
i don't connect with masculine pronouns
anymore
i've not abandoned my birth name i still
answer to nathaniel
but please um
she or they whichever one flows off the
tongue more easily for you
there was a point in the past where i
honestly didn't care and any pronoun was
fine
but um i would ask that you not use the
masculine pronoun
please thank you very much okay
i'm going to pop on over to the discord
which means this is the plug for the
patreon which gets you access to the
discord
is the other way to guarantee that you
have questions or comments read in the
live stream other than dropping super
chats
though i appreciate those as well
obviously
okay let's see what we've got here
um oh first question
first a couple of questions are actually
about the novel because that's what i
uh cause that's what i had mentioned was
kind of on my mind and that's the title
for this thing i really should be
writing right now but i'm not
um did you have a favorite character to
write for or one that came easily to you
two of my side characters of my novella
were like that oddly not the main
character yeah i
actually honestly the main character was
one of the hardest to write for
um which i know sounds
um counterintuitive
but like the i i knew there was a
certain character who i needed at the
center of this
to um to tell the story that i wanted to
tell
but the kind of character that that was
was not the easiest thing for me to
write
and if i did a drastic change on how
that main character functioned
it would have changed the story
significantly in terms of what i
actually wanted the narrative to be
so um but yeah i had a co i i
had a couple of characters there
there's honestly i'm not gonna name them
because the book's not out yet um so
the names would have no meaning anyways
but there are a couple of characters who
were
very easy for me to write because
they're basically
um me through a different lens i don't
want to go so far as to say self inserts
but there's a couple of characters where
one of them is basically how i
would like to think i would behave
in the circumstances that these
characters are in and the other
character is how i think i
probably actually would behave in
reality
if i was in those circumstances um
and so those two are actually quite easy
and we're a lot of fun to write um let
me get to the next
one
um can't wait to hear more about your
novel it's kind of nice and frustrating
at the same time when your thoughts are
consumed by your writing
i love it but it is frustrating when you
can't write and your head is throwing
ideas i'm working on becoming
a more disciplined writer myself i try
to write 2500 words a day right now
that is an impressive number um
once the book's actually done being
edited because that's still what
i'm that's what i'm trying to finish off
right now i
i want to maintain the habit of writing
on a daily basis
i'm not going to start out with a word
goal i'll sort of see what i get here's
what i found though
and i'll need to come up with a backup
plan for this
um come winter again but what i've
started doing
since it got warmer well i say that
supposed to snow here tomorrow
vermont but anyways i've actually
started writing out on my porch
um and writing outside
and it has done
worlds of wonder for my focus to not
be doing it in the same space at the
desk where i do everything else
because if i'm at the desk where i'm
normally editing
or researching for videos or
checking social media or what have you
then it's really hard to stop myself
from
doing those things either instead of or
at the same time that i'm trying to
write and then being
massively inefficient at all of them um
whereas going outside
and sitting on the porch i it's has done
wonders to clear my headspace and allow
me to focus
now come winter i can't really sit out
there i might try sitting in just
another room of the house to do writing
um but i do think i've learned one of
the things about me is that
i i really do kind of tie mental head
space
to my situation and my surroundings
so if i have built a habit of doing
certain things
at a certain location it's hard for me
to break that
if i'm trying to do something else i
should probably do it in a different
location where
i'm either used to doing that other
thing or i don't have specific habits
built up of doing
only this thing in this space if that
makes any kind of sense
uh let's see setting aside what we're
clearly for very young kids are there
any series print tv or film that you
feel you've simply
grew out of uh this exclusive ones that
became problematic simply a function of
how you changed
um i
don't think so
there are some that i have that i enjoy
greatly but have
been reluctant to go back and revisit
but that's more
fear of finding problematic elements um
i don't think
there's anything that i just flat out
outgrew
there were things i moved away from over
time like there was a time
when i was really into the um the dris
driss durden books so that's
um ari salvatore
um d d forgotten realms set books
uh the league character is a is a dark
elf i was really into those for a while
um i think after the third
trilogy i um
i like read the next one after that and
then i just kind of
i didn't bounce off it but i just didn't
pick up the next one after that and
didn't feel massively inclined to catch
up on it later
that's about the only one that i could
think of though
um for the most part uh if i've
moved away from stuff it's usually
because like there's been a reason a
substantive
often problematic material related
reason
um but honestly i still
i still hang on to a lot of stuff that i
loved
um as a kid so i
think part of me is reluctant to just
grow
out of stuff i don't think that's part
of my normal
process uh p.s if you want to do some
writing sprints while streaming tonight
we could write with you just a thought
um you know what
if come next live stream if i'm still
working on the book at it
i might have it be writing sprints
hopefully i'm done by then
we'll see but i hope so
um couple more is it bad that i call you
vera because i'm too lazy to type out
nathaniel nope makes total sense to me
uh i don't know if anyone has asked you
this probably have was doctor who your
first fandom
no goodness no star wars star wars was
my first fandom
um i didn't get into doctor who until
i was in my 20s um so
nope that that was definitely not my
first all right popping on back
to the stream
that is not where i wanted to go that's
where i wanted to go hey
there we go ah
bit random should gotham have done a
musical episode
i don't know if they should have uh
whether or not they should have
i think um
um but um well i think it depends
on uh whether or not enough of the cast
could
sing which i don't know if they could um
they could have gotten away with it
i haven't seen falcon in the winter
soldier because
from what i've seen they turned my great
grandfather into a murdering psychopath
my great-grandfather fought in world war
ii so i tie him with cap
i mean the thing to keep in mind is that
the
guy currently um carrying the shield
john walker
is not steve rogers and has no
ties to world war ii the way steve
rogers did
and his ability to carry or his failure
to carry
that legacy is kind of key to the story
so i feel like you are making a leap
there
that the show itself does not make
on the twitch live stream i like that
you said
you thought my name was lovely well it
is
so there you go um
do you think uh the 456 are the most
detestable villains in the doctor who
universe if not who do you think is ooh
[Music]
um they would definitely be in the
conversation
it uh
i'd put them on the short list i don't
want to say that
definitively
because i feel like i'd have to think
about that
but definitely um right up there
would it be fair to describe you as the
hostess of the council oh absolutely
can you hum yeah
so so far as i know
basically anybody can hum but okay
excuse me uh
was going to ask what do you think of
nathaniel no
no i i hate nickname i hate
plays on nathaniel like i hate nicknames
i hate shortenings of it
yeah no it's that just sounds so
wrong to my ear on like a gut level
uh appreciate the the thought i see what
you were going for
by that no no
um i saw the dvd of the first two
jeepers creepers films
which i got long before i knew what the
director had done yeah
i had
i had the first film on dvd i did get
rid of it
ultimately i never bought the second one
on dvd because the second one wasn't a
very good movie
regardless i did think that first one
um oh i missed the super chat oh
thank you carowind sorry i'm backing up
i'm backing up i'm backing up
thank you she keeps me in line
um yeah jeepers creepers that that
second one i just
did not think was a was a good movie
regardless
okay here we go here we go jimmy
jonathan lee i am sorry i missed it
earlier i might have been in the discord
i should have scrolled back up through
you get a heart thank you i hope you're
still in the chat
hope you're doing well do you think
nostalgia is the albatross that limits
new ideas with the jj
abrams star wars films and the backlash
towards
jeff johns um
sort of here's what i will say
is that i feel like
a nostalgia is an issue however the way
that we talk about it
is going to vary because there are some
people who who will argue that
the problem is the nostalgia that the
creators like jj abrams himself
has that is the problem
others would argue that it is the
nostalgia of the
fandom that is the problem and causes
them to respond the way they do
i'm actually going to kind of split the
difference
i think the creators
going in with deliberate intention to
appeal to nostalgia
is kind of where a lot of the problems
start
it's what meant the star wars films
other than last jedi which
i didn't like but it did try to step
outside of nostalgia a bit
um those films
they desperately wanted to appeal to
people's nostalgic sensibilities
and having that as your goal
at the same level or possibly even as a
higher priority
than telling a good story
it the relationship between
fan and creator um or fan and ip holder
more realistically is a very fraught one
and there's a lot of back and forth in
it that i think is kind of unhealthy for
everybody involved at times
because the there can be an echo chamber
and the fact that
fans um
have more direct access to creators
than they ever have before i think makes
an existing problem worse
because nostalgia is a funny thing
ultimately when you have
serious nostalgia for something
what you want from it is something
that's impossible
at your heart for star wars fans
who have nostalgia for the earlier
films what they want seeing the new
films is to
feel the way they felt when they saw the
originals
and you can't these aren't the same
movies
made by the same people but more
importantly you are not the same person
nothing can capture truly
that same feeling that you had when you
were however old you were when you first
fell in love with this property
but that's that is the high that fans
keep chasing and
some have a healthier understanding that
you know of what they can get
from continuing to engage with the
property than others but there are
definitely some who seem to get angry
when it doesn't make them feel the way
they felt when they first fell in love
with it
but nothing will nothing ever could
and it's and knowing that there are
creators and companies trying to
monetize that desire and that
wish that impossible wish to
feel the way you did however long ago
yeah it's a little bit of a mess
oh we got another one theo the otaku cat
thank you oh your icon's adorable
did you know there's a labyrinth
tabletop rpg
i i think i did
but i'd forgotten about because that is
ringing a vague bell i think i like
i think i saw something about it like
when it first came out
but i couldn't afford it so it just kind
of slipped out of uh
out of my head after that have you seen
the flash
tv i saw the first two seasons um
started the third season got really sick
of saying
damn it barry and stopped do you ever
think about your daughter possibly being
greater than you
i mean i hope she is i mean broadly
speaking
we don't she doesn't share
my kinds of ambitions so like
she has never expressed a desire to
be a youtuber or to write a book and she
does have things that she is passionate
about but they are
pursuits different from what i have
pursued
so the idea of comparing her is you know
greater than me given that we at least
at present
the age she's at she's not pursuing the
same things that i am pursuing
um it just seems like an odd comparison
to make
to me no i meant can you hum on the live
stream
uh no because if i start humming a tomb
that's copyrighted i
risk getting flagged and i won't do it
what if you switch bodies with doom [ __ ]
i
wouldn't know it because i imagine that
that helmet is not his actual head so i
have no clue what he looks like
i would be terrified to find out
i'd also be a man again which
no i i like my boobs too much so that's
that's a hard no
do you have any favorite doctor who
novels not the good doctor i actually
have
read very very very few and really only
in
audiobook form so not really in a
position to answer that
uh this is talk about nostalgia reminds
me of why some of my favorite doctor
who's stories
critique nostalgia such as dr falls and
jubilee
interesting
i also recently and regretfully got the
blu-ray of primer
and uh upstream color
because i was completely unaware of what
shane
uh karuth has been accused of oh
has he i was unaware
oh i mean
i saw a primer
and i could appreciate what it
was but i didn't enjoy it
so never got around to upstream color
but
honestly what saddens me most about
those accusations when they land
is less the idea of oh this is a piece
of media i won't be able to enjoy again
and it saddens me more the idea of
how many people did they hurt
before this went public before this came
out
how big a fan of tmnt are you um
moderately um i read the original comics
not at the time they came out
but i bought like collections of the
original comics like first four volumes
i read and re-read those loved those
um watched the first
the first three movies and
the um
uh the cgi one um
got some degree of entertainment out of
all of them i wasn't an
avid watcher of the original cartoon
um i think honestly that's something
that i kind of grew out not ninja
turtles as a general thing but just how
cartoonish that specific cartoon was
um i had a lot of the toys for a while
i did enjoy uh tmnt i have not gone back
to it maybe
maybe that's what i've grown out of but
then again i don't know because i
haven't really taken the time to try and
go back
i feel like star wars seven eight and
nine are not canon in my head only one
to six
plus the mandalorian clone wars and
other star wars stuff we're getting
our canon in my head um
the main reason why i
i would consider them non-canon but the
main reason that i won't
sink too many too many of my thoughts
into star wars seven or
eight or nine is more just because
actually on premise the um
the fact that the first order rose up
basically means that my heroes didn't
win
at the end of return of the jedi they
didn't get to just
win and be victorious and
be happy because effectively the exact
same threat rose up again
and that is actually
my biggest
fundamental issue with those movies i
have
issues with each one individually
but broadly speaking the fact that it
negates the happy ending
of return of the jedi i consider that to
kind of be the original sin
and that's not a that's not a retcon for
me you can go back
i don't know if they're still up ryan
daly had
a podcast called dead bothen spies
that he had me on this was before force
awakens comes out and i
talked about this having this problem on
premise so i'm not pulling this one on
my butt i've been hammering this one for
a while
um oh thank you
thomas you get a heart
are you a fan of mystery science theater
3000 by any chance yes
again i would say casually
um i've never like um
really muscled through um all their
stuff but i
i've enjoyed what i've seen i think the
one i've seen the most times was
the movie um where they did this island
earth
uh i really uh i really did enjoy that
one that's sort of the one that tends to
leap to mind it's the one i know the
most quotes from
oh suddenly i have a refreshing mint
flavor
they're magnetized and if your hands
were metal that would mean something
um i i do enjoy mst3k it's good stuff
seeing as the simpsons has gotten the
news because of it benedict
cumberbatch's morrissey impression is on
point
okay i'll take your word for that do you
like s'mores
yeah sure um in the summer
so it's a little early for them yet
uh i am going to wrap it up soon ryan's
great i hope he can show up here again
uh after covid times i am i'm trying to
finish up editing
i did a catch-up with him and paul
that'll go up on the break room i'm
trying to wrap up editing it but it's a
pain in my butt um but yeah so
there'll be a little bit of a catch-up
at least um
you don't have time you don't have to
hung hum a song just hum in general
there you go i've hummed
okay
aw too soon i
it's i've been going for about an hour
um and yeah i hold on
is this about done i've got a
i've got a video rendering now that's
almost done
i'm not sure what i'm going to do i
might
uh i might try what is it with the
humming i don't
know ask ms wicked wolf she's the one
who kept bringing it up
um managed to wrangle paul i'm impressed
as you should be yes
paul's a very difficult wrangle um oh
uh so twitch tomorrow
at 10 a.m eastern time i will be on my
twitch channel
twitch.tv council of geeks i will be
futzing around on hearthstone again
um that is probably what i will continue
to
play until i get a better computer
but um yeah
so yeah there you go
uh you want to catch up with me in the
morning that's where i'll be
i hope everybody has a good rest of the
evening
i don't know what i'm going to do with
mine i'll figure that out
but um take care of yourself
be safe i know more people are getting
vaccinated but
don't don't jump the gun
be safe out there be kind
and please remember that you are
beautiful
you are valid and you are loved
you are the council i
just run the meetings and until next
time
this council is adjourned
by kevin